What's happenin mah well read ballas?
This week we gettin red tape up in that ASS with
The Trial by Franz Kafka.
Banker-man Joseph K. just turned 30 and now
he chillin at the crib waitin' fo some grub.
S'all good til- KNOCK KNOCK.
"Man dat BETTER be my foo-."
"Huh?
Who this suit rollin up on my spot?"
Apparently, this tight-ass dude representin
da law and lay it on K-baby raw: "You under
arrest, son."
"WHAAA?!
What I even do?"
But this cat and his boy keep their mouths
shut and don't give him no reason.
So deez haters take K next door where there
be a ghetto-rigged court sesh goin down.
Da top dawg inspector start runnin his mouth
bout how K is in some deep shit, but he STILL
don't say why!
Da hell?
K walks for now, but this mess sho' as hell
ain't over.
Not even close.
Later, word come from the law dat K gotta
bust ass to court without tellin him what
time, or the room number where all this goin
down'.
Afta' sweatin his nuts off just tryna find
this place, he finally get to an attic in
a hood-ass building where da judge like "Boy
you an hour and five minutes late!"
Psh.
So K step up and rock the mic sayin this system
is straight CROOKED, but nobody give a damn
bout what he got to say.
Later, K-baby on the grind when he hear somethin
funky- "Aw hell no.. people best not be gettin
freaky in MY bank- Uhhh..what da hell is goin
on?".
Apparently the suits who arrested K gettin
whooped on cuz K ratted on them in court fo'
tryna' boost his swag.
K feel mad guilty, and wanna put a stop to
this mess, but da whippin man aint backin'
down fo' nothing.
Brutha gotta do what he gotta do.
Then K's uncle drop in and be all like "You
takin this case seriously boy?
Yo ass is on the LINE!"
So K's uncle introduces him to a lawyer named
Huld and his BANGIN' nurse Leni.
Mmm-mmm-MMM YEAH!
But Huld is completely f*ckin useless.
Brutha ain't got a clue why K got the law
up his ass and there ain't nuthin he can do.
And if dat aint cray 'nuff, the Chief Clerk
of da court was just chillin in the shadows
this whole damn time just diddlin himself
o' somethin.
As time go by, K keep hittin up his lawyer,
but this shyster never do jack sh*t!
Now K buggin so hard bout da case that a customer
roll up at work and be like: "Psst bruh.
You should talk to my homey Titorelli.
He work up at the court so he know what's
what."
So K hit up Titorelli, who all like "Real
talk.
You're basically fucked.
They ain't never gonna call you innocent so
you might as well just bend over."
Now K thinkin' he gotta shake his punk-ass
lawyer.
So he swang over to the office where this
raggedy dude named Block be chillin.
Apparently, Block was ballin' as a businessman
back in the day, but since the law came down
on his ass like they doin to K, he spent all
his cheddar on legal defense and now he all
cashed out on the struggle.
When K try to break it off with Huld, da lawyer
like "Not so fast, bruh.
You walk away, and you ain't gonna be nuthin
but a dog like Block."
Then the bank tell K he gotta show one of
their big dawg clients round town.
Dude say he wanna peep game at the cathedral,
but when he a no show, K just check spot himself.
Befo' he but to leave, da priest holler and
tell him he work for da court too.
He try to explain K's bunk-ass sitiation with
a fable, but it don't mean a damn thing to
K.
A year go by since all this craziness first
went down.
On da night before K's 31st birthday, two
suits arrive at his crib.
This time, though, K ain't trippin bout it.
Matta' fact, K take the lead and they head
to a quarry where K put his head a boulder.
Then one of the suits shank him right in the
heart and TWIST.
K's last words befo' he take that long dirt
nap: "Like a dog!"
Man this trap Joey-K livin' in sho one crooked-ass
place.
Brutha ain't got no rights, no voice, and
no options- da law got his nuts in a vice
and there ain't nuthin he can do bout it.
But da scurriest thang Kafka preachin is dat
it don't take a hardass thug puttin a glock
to yo dome in order to take away yo dignity
n' freedom.
Naw blood, up in this hood homies are broken
down by a slow, orderly system dat's designed
to keep people in check even though it frontin'
like it all righteous.
Like check this- Even though K never do any
time behind bars, it ain't cuz things all
good.
Truth is, they don't need to throw K in the
slammer since erry-day in this society is
like livin' in the pen anyway - "You have misunderstood
me.
You are under arrest, certainly, but that
not need hinder you from going about your
business.
Nor will you be prevented from leading your
ordinary life."
Yuh, the man all the way up K's ass for this
whole damn book.
But just cuz they the law sho as hell don't
mean they preachin justice.
Matta fact, the "law" could be da most un-just
thang you eva' seen- but when you got people
follow it blindly, and enforce it just cuz
"it's their job"- da fact dat it ain't just
don't even matta'.
Da law s'posed to protect yo' rights.
But up in here, it's nuthin' mo' than a weapon
to keep you scurred and in yo place.
"Our officials... never go hunting for crime
in the populace, but, as the Law decrees,
are drawn toward the guilty and must then
send out us warders.
That is the Law.
How could there be a mistake in that?"
It's like K-money livin' a totalitarian nightmare.
Matta' fact, Kafka style-game makin this whole
novel feel like a tripped out dream.
Fo example, when K up in court, he try chunk
deuce outta there, but the magistrate just
pop up in front of the door like he teleporting
or something.
Da hell?
Or when he meeting with his lawyer, da Chief
Clerk just appear in da corner of da room
like he been creepin in da shadows this whole
time.
What the hell is he doin over there?
Thang is tho, a few years after Kafka was
runnin the lit game, this shit wasn't a dream
no mo'.
It ended up coming true.
This whole society sound like some kinda totalitarian
prophecy- all da fear and isolation deez whack-ass
places used were hella-similar to Joseph K's
society- straight down to the threadz the
po-lice wore.
And da most fucked up thing bout it ain't
da way they can break yo bones, but da way
they can break you spirit.
And that's exactly the point.
Evil ain't gotta be some moustache twirling
playa doin gangsta shit.
Sometimes da gnarliest evil is a boring-ass
bureaucracy that wears yo ass down day by
day with bullshit rights and corrupt systems
dat make yo life such a living hell dat you
don't even know what you fightin fo' no mo.
A society like dat can dehumanize you so much
dat you just wanna be takin out back and put
down.
BAM- like a dog.
Yo thanks for kickin it with yo boy.
Catch y'all next time.
Peace!